[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I'd like to introduce
now our second panel.
We will begin our second panel.
And this is Harvard and Slavery.
Annette Gordon-Reed will be
the moderator for that panel.
Annette Gordon-Reed is the
Charles Warren Professor
of American Legal History
at Harvard Law School
and Professor of
History at Harvard.
And she won the 2009 Pulitzer
Prize and many, many prizes
for her book The
Hemingses of Monticello.
Annette.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you very much.
It's wonderful to be here.
Also, I'd like to say that I
was for five years the Carol K.
Pforzheimer Radcliffe professor.
The term ended last year.
And I had to come back to
Earth, into the real world,
and actually do some work.
So, I'm very, very
happy to be here
under the auspices of Radcliffe.
I'm going to introduce
our panelists,
distinguished panelists, in
order of their presentation.
Sven Beckert is the Laird Bell
Professor of History at Harvard
University and an author of the
much-acclaimed book on slavery
and capitalism, Empire of
Cotton:A Global History.
Sven has been
interested in slavery
at Harvard for a number of
years and did a research project
with students called the
Harvard Research Project,
Slavery Project.
Then, we will have
Alexandra Rahman,
who was a student of Sven's,
who did her thesis on slavery
and was involved in the Harvard
and Slavery Research Project.
Dan Coquillette, who
is from Boston College
and is also now the
Charles Warren Visiting
Professor of American Legal
History at the law school,
Harvard Law School.
Among other things,
Dan is a specialist
on the royal family,
whose contribution
was the seed money for the
creation of the Harvard Law
School.
And finally, we'll
have Julian Bonder,
an award-winning architect
who is active contributor
to international debates on
slavery, memory, architecture,
and art and
representation, and will
talk to us about
architecture and memory
at the end of the presentation.
So, to give you
some ground rules,
each presenter will speak
for about 15 minutes.
We will then take
a time afterwards
to have a conversation
among ourselves,
but we really want to get
questions from you all.
You know from the beginning
that you write your questions.
I will take questions from
all of the various audiences,
here, in the overflow room.
If you're on Twitter or social
media, write your questions
and I'll try to get
those in as well.
So, that's the order of the day.
So, we'll start with Sven.
- Thank you so much, Annette.
It's great to be here.
Good afternoon.
I'm delighted that so many of
you decided to come out here
today to join us.
And I'm especially delighted
at the enormous response
that this conference
has generated,
which I think very much speaks
to the urgency of the issues
that we're debating
here, and perhaps
also is a hopeful sign that
we are able to confront
our histories in new ways.
When we've shown
ability and willingness
to face the darkest
moments of our history,
I become more hopeful about
our future, a future that
needs to rest on a full
and truthful accounting
of our past.
I'm personally very much moved
by the turnout here today
and by the interest that
you all have been taking
in these matters, not least
because the engagement
with this history
here at Harvard
began as a decisively
low-key affair.
10 years ago, in 2007, I
sat in a small seminar room
in the Yard with
a very small group
of undergraduate students,
exactly four of them,
who had signed up for a seminar
taught by a professor who
did not know more about
the topic of the course
than they did.
I had been inspired to offer
that Harvard and Slavery
seminar by President Ruth
Simmons's path-breaking work
at Brown University.
And I was also inspired
by my upbringing
in Germany, which had taught
me that almost anywhere
some dark history lurks.
It was these students
that the work
to excavate with-- it was these
students who began the work
to excavate the historical
connections between Harvard
and slavery.
And in a very real
sense, it is they
who have enabled us
to meet here today.
And I very much want
to thank them again
for all of their
work, and some of them
are here right now, so--
[APPLAUSE]
In the past few
hours, we have heard
moving testimony about
the legacy of slavery
at American universities.
We've heard about colleges
buying and selling
enslaved workers,
about students bringing
their enslaved servants
to their campuses,
about presidents,
faculties, alumni
and donors of these
institutions as slaveholders,
about how enslaved
construction workers built
the physical infrastructure
of various universities,
and how the huge stream of
money derived from the slave
economy infused institutions
of higher learning
and enabled them,
among other things,
to train an elite that
legitimated notions
of racial difference
and enslavement
and enforced the institutions
that had enabled them.
A little more than
260 years ago,
it was three Harvard
University-trained judges
who convicted Phyllis, an
enslaved worker accused
of killing her master, to be
burned at the stake just a few
hundred yards away from where
we are meeting right now.
This story and many
others are moving,
and they are disturbing.
We can see that some
of our most esteemed
educational
institutions are also
the product of some of the most
horrific violence that has ever
descended upon any
group of people.
Yes, we did know that much
of the wealth of the American
South had been
built upon slavery,
that its roads, its canals,
its plantations, and its cities
were the result of the
exploitation of millions
of African-Americans.
But today at this
conference, we learned
that the centers of higher
learning, of debate,
of the great
humanistic traditions
of the Western world, of
our cherished enlightenment
traditions, were also built at
least partly upon the violence
of the slave trader, the
Middle Passage, the auction
block, and the whip.
We are rightly disturbed
by these histories,
but if we sit back and think
about the broader context,
we should not be too
surprised that slavery
was central to the institutions
of higher education
as they emerged
in North America.
After all, for
several centuries,
North America was part of the
great belt of slave plantation
economies that stretched
from South America
through the
Caribbean all the way
to the borders of New Jersey.
Yet here in Boston,
and here at Harvard,
the story of slavery that has
been told for all too long
is different.
New England is hailed
in the national memory
as a place of freedom, a place
where religious dissenters
settled on the stony
soils of New England
to create a new world
of liberty and freedom.
And thus, if we look at the
history of the institutions
of higher learning, including
the history of Harvard,
we have taught this
history, and they
have taught these
histories about themselves,
as exactly this story, as
a story of the expansion
of human freedom.
Or at least they have
done so until recently.
When I first embarked
upon the project
of trying to understand
the historical relationship
between Harvard University
and slavery with my students,
the literature on the
history of Harvard
was almost silent on
the question of slavery.
And when the students began to
uncover a different history,
they and others who listened
to them were surprised.
Yet in retrospect, it seems
that the only thing that
should surprise us
was our surprise
and that it took us so long
for us to allow ourselves to be
surprised by that history.
After all, a whole range
of studies, many of them
quite old, had argued
for the continental reach
and the importance of slavery.
People such as Eric Williams and
WEB Du Bois and Ronald Bailey,
among many others,
had powerfully
argued for the nationwide or
even global reach of slavery.
And it would have been unlikely
that the oldest university
in North America
would not in some ways
be also involved in that
story of slavery as well.
In dusty archival records,
countless published volumes
in the libraries, and by careful
study of Harvard's oldest
buildings and neighboring
colonial graveyards, students
uncovered many links
between Harvard and slavery.
They chronicled how
Harvard presidents
brought enslaved workers to
live with them on campus.
They analyzed how significant
gifts to the university
were drawn from the
exploitation of slave labor.
They found evidence for some
of Harvard's endowment invested
in merchant voyages related
to the slave economy.
They showed how
Harvard's administration
favored the suppression
of public debates
on [? slavering, ?] fearing a
backlash from the local Boston
elite.
Harvard-trained judges
condemned an enslaved woman,
as we just heard, to be burned
on the stake just a few hundred
yards away from here.
The students charted how
the sons of Southern slave
owners who returned
after college
to a lifetime of violent
mastery over their workers
mingled on campus with the
sons of the Northern elites,
forging networks that
often lasted a lifetime.
The students traced the
history of Antiguan planter
who became a major funder
of the Harvard Law School.
More generally,
the students show
how the deep immersion of
Boston's merchant community
with the plantation
economy of the Caribbean,
yielded resources
for the university.
They analyzed how Harvard
acquired one of Cuba's largest
sugar plantations, a plantation
whose owner, Ed Atkins,
provided resources for
the university to draw on.
And these resources were
derived from the labor
of his enslaved workers.
And students were
also able to show
how the development of some of
the most viciously racist ideas
were spearheaded by the
members of the Harvard faculty.
Indeed, what the
students found was
that Harvard's
connection to slavery
extended beyond the
abolition of slavery
in Massachusetts in
the 1780s, and it even
extended beyond the abolition
of slavery in the United States
in 1865.
In the process of
doing this research
students have made
a larger point.
They have shown that
the history of slavery
is the history of the
nation as a whole.
Even in acknowledging
the crimes of slavery,
we have all too often settled
into a seemingly comfortable
fiction that slavery was a
regional institution, confined
by the 19th century to the
states of the American South,
with Northerners
principally involved
with slavery by bringing
about its abolition.
Slavery, in fact, appears
as limited in scope,
an unfortunate detour on the
nation's march to modernity,
and certainly not as one of the
engines of America's economy.
But as the students
have shown, slavery
was not a regional institution
or a regional problem.
Slavery was everywhere, in
the merchant houses of Boston,
the banks of New York, the
factories of Rhode Island,
and the universities
throughout New England.
Such recognition of the
continent-spanning importance
of slavery, in turn, also gives
a much greater appreciation
for those Americans who had
the courage and the resolve
to stand up against
slavery, among them
members of the
Harvard community,
and for those
Americans who would
die in battle
during the Civil War
to bring about emancipation,
among them also
members of the
Harvard community.
Recognizing the
power of slavery,
including the power
of slavery at Harvard,
does put into much
sharper relief
the courage and dedication
of those, black and white,
who fought against slavery.
They stood against some of
the most powerful interests
of their own times.
As historians and as
members of this community,
our first commitment
is to uncovering
the historical truth.
Part of that truth is
the deep entanglement
of this institution with
slavery and also with some
of the racism, exploitation,
and repression that
descended upon
African-Americans after slavery.
This history is inscribed
in this institution,
and it is also inscribed
in the nation as a whole.
The economic,
cultural, ideological,
and political legacy of
slavery and its aftermath
is with us today.
It is not just history.
It is our present.
Slavery is our present.
As members of this
university and as members
of our national
community, we need
to confront these histories.
We cannot successfully move
forward as a university,
as a nation, or as citizens
without acknowledging this
history and making it
important to the understanding
of our present.
And to be meaningful,
that acknowledgement
will have to have economic
and political consequences.
It cannot be purely
symbolic or rhetorical.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hello, everyone, and
thank you so much again
for the introductions.
My presentation
today has two parts.
First, I will quickly
introduce myself
and my association with the
Harvard and Slavery Project.
And second, I will take
you through an example
of some scholarship on
Harvard and slavery,
which is the findings of
my senior thesis, entitled
Plantation University:
Harvard Scientists at Soledad
Plantation--
I'm sorry, Harvard Scientists
at Soledad Plantation
and Cuba's Transition from
Slavery to Free Labor,
1880 to 1920.
And as my presentation
will go on,
and looking at this thesis
several years later,
I realize 1920 is actually not
a great time to cut this off.
The connection actually
extends much further than that.
So, to start, my
name is Alexa Rahman,
and I'm currently
a doctoral student
at Harvard Business
School, studying
accounting, management, and
corporate accountability.
I got involved in this field
when I took Professor Beckert's
Harvard and Slavery
research seminar when
I was a freshman at
Harvard College in 2009.
I was interested in
this class because I
had heard of
historians discovering
other links between
slavery and universities
at our peer schools like Brown.
And I was curious to see if
we at Harvard had similar ties
to the history of slavery that
we simply didn't know about.
My research focused
on a research facility
that Harvard maintained on
a sugar plantation named
Soledad in Cuba in the late
1800s to the mid 1900s.
That facility, called the
Harvard Botanic Station,
was created by the
two figures that you
can see here on this slide.
Edwin Atkins, to the left, was
a prominent Boston businessman,
West Indian sugar
merchant, and slave owner,
who purchased Soledad
Plantation in 1884.
Oakes Ames, to the right, was
a Harvard professor of botany.
In the aftermath of Cuban
slave emancipation in 1886,
Atkins wished to apply the
latest scientific knowledge
in agricultural engineering
to boost production
at Soledad Plantation.
In 1899, he collaborated
with Professor Ames
to develop the Harvard
Botanic Station at Soledad
to conduct research on sugarcane
to support his business.
This relationship, I
argue in my thesis,
would forge a profitable
but problematic link
between the history of
Harvard and the history
of Caribbean slavery.
My thesis makes
three main arguments.
First, it contends
that by accepting gifts
from Edwin Atkins in
the early 20th century,
Harvard used wealth and land
accumulated by slave labor
as scholarly resources.
This follows from evidence
that Atkins's family wealth
was dependent on the West
Indian slave economy.
Second, it argues that
the social and business
ties between Atkins
and Harvard personnel
resulted in significant
financial donations
to the institution, which drew
on the Atkins family fortune.
Lastly, and perhaps
most important,
it asserts that Edwin Atkins's
construction of the Harvard
Botanic Station at Soledad
provided a significant gift
to the university's
academic assets.
I'll begin by just
providing a short background
on the sources of Edwin Atkins's
personal wealth, which he later
used to finance
Harvard researchers.
During the 19th century,
the Atkins family,
based in Belmont,
Massachusetts, rose to riches
by trading goods
manufactured by slaves,
mainly sugar and molasses,
in the West Indies.
When Edwin Atkins took
over the family business,
he assumed ownership
of the Soledad sugar
plantation, a 900-acre refinery
with approximately 177 slaves.
Cuban slave
emancipation in 1886,
as I mentioned
previously, coincided
with a period of
major innovations
in industrial production
technology, which also included
agricultural engineering.
Other innovations, such as
steam powered refineries,
rail transport, and
cable communication all
transformed the sugar
production business
just as the country
was beginning to shift
from slave labor to free labor.
Atkins, eager to keep
up with his competitors,
invested heavily in new
production technologies
and approached Harvard
professor Ames precisely
to help his business
successfully
navigate this transition
from slave production
to mechanized production.
Drawing on his Cuban
fortune, Atkins
made significant donations
of cash, scholarships,
and academic resources to
Harvard from 1899 to 1925,
enabling students and
professors to conduct research
on improving the quality
and yield of tropical plants
such as sugarcane.
His largest single donation,
which was $17,119 in 1919,
was to establish the
Atkins Fund for Tropical
Research in Economic Botany.
This gift would be worth a
little over half a million
dollars today.
Physical research spaces like
the Harvard Botanic Station
helped transport
intellectual power
from the halls of academia
and apply it directly
to issues on the plantation.
Ames and Atkins's
partnership culminated
in 1925, when they constructed
the official Harvard
House, a boarding house with
bedrooms and a laboratory space
for Harvard students to conduct
research at the plantation
under the management
of the university.
And what you see here is an
image from the inside of one
of those labs in 1930
on the plantation.
In recognition of Atkins's
long and profitable patronage,
Harvard president
Charles Elliott
even awarded Atkins
an honorary degree
at the 1903 commencement.
So, although slavery
ended in 1886,
the physical, cultural, and
ideological legacy of slavery
remained palpable
to Harvard scholars
as they continued to
conduct research at Soledad.
To emphasize this point I've
included a quote from a letter
that Professor Ames wrote on
one of his research visits
to the plantation.
He writes, "The slave
bell on the plantation
rang out one single,
musical, but dull note.
And I really felt that
all the cruelty of slavery
was summoned in
that one bell tone.
My subsequent
thoughts were perhaps
similar to those of some
compassionate creature, who
suddenly awakened
in days gone by,
to the atrocities of holding
in bondage one's fellow man,
and driving him to
and from his work
by the note of a
doleful bell, aided
by this stinging lash,
which injures one far
deeper than steel or bronze."
And I should add this isn't--
I didn't include the rest
of the letter on the slide,
but it's interesting
that he doesn't actually
go on to address that
this is a problem.
He goes on to talk about how
this is a issue that people
must have faced a long
time ago and isn't
antiquity fascinating.
This was written like about 20
years after the end of slavery.
And he was working
for the slave-owner
who perpetrated these crimes.
So, just interesting.
I know we had talked
earlier about people back
then maybe didn't realize
it was a bad thing.
This is an example of someone
recognizing it and willfully
ignoring it.
So, despite these
mixed feelings,
apparently, about
working at Soledad,
Ames visited his
facilities in Cuba often,
bringing back data to supplement
his science classes at Harvard.
Students and
instructors continued
to use the site for
decades to come,
leaving behind a trail
of photographs, sketches,
and Crimson articles documenting
their time at the plantation.
The university maintained
control of the research
facilities until
travel became difficult
during the communist
Cuban revolution.
And the last director
of the Harvard station
left the island in 1961.
So, to summarize,
my thesis argued
that Atkins's donations of
funds and academic resources
sprang from wealth and lands
directly dependent on profits
from trading West
Indian slave products
and eventually owning
Soledad Plantation.
Harvard benefited from
the Atkins's fortune
by accepting financial
and educational gifts,
in operating Ames's
very own Harvard Botanic
Station for over half a century
on the very grounds of Soledad
Plantation.
The images on this slide
illustrate Harvard professors
harvesting papayas on
the station in 1924,
as well as an image of a
sign bearing Harvard's name
that was found at the
plantation in 2005.
In conclusion, I
believe these findings
demonstrate the importance
of investigating connections
between Harvard and slavery.
I hope that this research will
allow us to better understand
and recognize how the
history of slavery
has contributed to the
development of our school's
vast educational resources,
which we still enjoy today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, I'm Dan
Coquillette and I'm the--
along with my distinguished
colleague, Bruce Kimball,
co-director of the Harvard
Law School History Project
and co-author of a new book,
On the Battlefield of Merit,
which is the first of two
volumes, a new critical history
of Harvard Law School.
I just tell you those two
volumes-- those are not books
that you can't put down.
Those are books
you can't pick up.
[LAUGHTER]
But otherwise, perfect
gift for your uncle Ralph.
I mean--
[LAUGHTER]
The Harvard Law School History
Project sounds very fancy.
But in fact, it's
right along the lines
of what Sven and
Alexandra have been doing.
We're a group of volunteers.
We did get some grant
funding upfront,
but we're not official.
We're people that work together.
We meet every month.
It consists of PhDs,
JDs, and particularly,
students working with
us and specialist
librarians to undertake a whole
series of research initiatives.
We've done 100 oral histories,
not just of faculty, but also
staff, and also of
students and alumni.
And so, this is a--
we believe that thanks to this
project, Harvard Law School
is one of the best documented
of all institutions of higher
learning in the United States.
Now you may ask, well,
why is that important?
I have to be very sensitive
here and not arrogant.
We have neighbors to the
south in New Haven that
are overly sensitive
about their law school,
and even though it's
younger and much smaller.
And-- but the truth
is, for good or bad,
Harvard Law School is the
most powerful law school,
historically, in America.
And it remains-- just count
the Supreme Court justices--
it remains the most powerful.
That wasn't arrogant, was it?
No, just facts, just facts.
Now, we knew that On
the Battlefield of Merit
was going to be controversial.
I mean, we knew.
And the things that
we were prepared for
was, first, the research
on the Civil War.
Harvard Law School was
next only to West Point
the leading source of military
officers for the Confederacy--
13 major generals, 60 colonels
of Southern regiments.
Almost as many Harvard
Law School students
died fighting for slavery as
died fighting against slavery.
And that was because
during the entire period
of the 1840s and
1850s, Joseph Story,
Simon Greenleaf recruited--
to make a national law
school by recruiting
in Georgia, Atlanta and--
in Atlanta and in
Savannah and Charleston.
So, we knew about that.
We also knew that
Christopher Columbus
Langdell and his disciples
were fervently anti-feminist.
We knew that they had
instilled a gender apartheid
system at the school
which lasted until 1950.
No women were admitted at
Harvard Law School until 1950.
I've talked to many
in the first class.
No women on the
faculty until 1971.
Now, I've talked to all of them.
So, this is-- there's
plenty of controversy there.
But what really got
the students excited,
and in retrospect, I
should've seen this coming, is
the establishment of Harvard
Law School as a foundation
based on slavery.
There's no doubt about it.
We knew, we knew early
on that Isaac Royall--
this is a portrayal of him
at age 24 with his wife
and sister-in-law
and daughters--
he was a slave owner.
We knew he had 20,
24 slaves in Medford.
What we did not know was
that Royall's fortune
was based on the Antiguan
sugar plantations.
The cruelty of those
plantations was beyond belief.
He owned 180 slaves with
his father on Antigua
in the Popes Head region.
Sugar slavery was very cruel.
They issued the slaves
knives, the enslaved people
knives every morning.
They had numbers
on them because you
had to turn the
knives in every night.
And they were razor sharp.
A single nick without
antibiotic and death
was almost inevitable.
The casualty rate
on these plantations
was extremely, extremely high.
The only reason
why Harvard School
is going to have
its bicentennial,
and it's going to be the oldest
school, law school in America,
is because the fortune that
Royall made in Antiguan sugar
was left in a bequest
in 1788 to Harvard
to establish a law professor.
The Royall Professorship
is one of the oldest
chairs at Harvard.
It's occupied right now
with great distinction
by Janet Halley, who
in her inauguration
gave tribute to the slaves
on which the chair is based.
But, you know it's--
as we got into
this, it got worse.
There was a major slave revolt
on the Royall plantation.
The revolt was
under a leadership
of a man, very brave
man, named King Court.
Unfortunately for them,
it was betrayed just
at the last moment.
There are only 27
white men on the island
capable carrying gun.
One was Isaac Royall.
There were 364 slaves.
But they-- white
men had the guns.
The uprising was betrayed,
it was suppressed,
and as a result, 77 enslaved
people were burned at the stake
by Royall and his friends.
They also-- the six leaders--
were drawn and quartered, and
King Court was gibbeted alive.
So, this gentleman
here, who founded
the Harvard Law School's
chair, which became
the center of the new school--
as his, one of his
descendants said,
I know he was a slave owner.
I hope he was a
nice slave owner.
And he wasn't a
This was a brutal slave owner.
Here's his house in Medford.
It's right, you know, 20
minutes drive from here.
Now that's the slave block.
The reason why he
came to Medford
was because of fear
of yellow fever,
but also fear of
another slave revolt.
He brought about
20 slaves with him.
They lived in this block.
You can-- some of us
have already been there.
You can visit it.
But this was his
household slaves.
You don't get a sense
of the industry,
the cruelty of the
industrial slavery
by looking at these quarters.
It was what was
going on in Antigua,
which was continuing to
support his family, that
was really, really brutal.
He fled to England
on the outbreak
of the American Revolution,
the Battle of Lexington.
Left his family in Medford.
He ran immediately to Halifax.
And when I introduce
the students coming in,
I show them the portrait
we've just seen.
I say, you know, brutal
slave owner, trader, coward.
Other than that, a perfect
role model for you.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, in 1936, Abbott
Lawrence Lowell,
who was an anglophile
of the first order,
decided that Oxford colleges
all had coats of arms,
so therefore residence
houses and schools at Harvard
all ought to have
coats of arms, too.
And so, for the
[INAUDIBLE] he decreed
coats of arms for everybody.
And that included
Radcliffe, but it also
included the law school.
And the genius who was
assigned the law school
decided that the
right coat of arms
should be Isaac
Royall's coat of arms.
So, there is a book
plate of Isaac Royall.
Isaac Royall of Antigua.
You see the three wheat sheaves.
And there is the coat of
arms of Harvard Law School
until last year.
They're identical.
Well, anyway, the students who
had worked on this research
project persuaded other
students to read the book.
And before anybody
knew it, they were in--
they had organized
Students for Inclusion.
Their motto was
Royall must fall.
And they took over
the major lounge
at the new Caspersen
Student Center,
declared it the
Belinda Lounge, which
is after the slave,
one of Royall's slaves,
and occupied it.
So, they were in
absolute seriousness.
And a committee was formed under
the chairmanship of Bruce Mann.
And that committee, after
a lot of deliberation,
decided to recommend to the
president and corporation
that the shield be revoked.
Now, that decision came with a--
what I think's one of
the most eloquent pieces
of writing I've ever seen.
And it's by our moderator,
Annette Gordon-Reed.
And in that, she
warned that you,
by just eliminating
a symbol, you
don't eliminate the
truth of the past.
And also worried that this
would cut the school off
from the debt it
owes to Antigua.
By the way, this is
what the students
thought of the Royall
coat of arms, right?
That's their view of it.
Well, anyway, here I
am, down on Antigua.
That's the Betty's Hope.
You see the great mills for
breaking up the sugarcane.
I was down there talking
to leaders in the Antiguan
community, educational
leaders and the head
of their national government,
and their secretary
of education.
And I was talking
about the consciousness
of the island and its connection
with Harvard Law School.
First of all, it turns
out that the curriculum
in the high schools all
mention Isaac Royall
and mention the slave revolt.
So, every high school student
learns this story.
And secondly, that
they're absolutely
mindful of the connection
between the island
and this university.
At one point when
talking to Michele Henry,
the president of
the National Museum,
I really was just overcome.
I mean, they had
showed me some things
which they just don't normally
show tourists, of course, which
is the holding pens for the
slaves, that have survived,
and the dungeons where they
hung slaves by their wrists
and which are back
in the jungle.
And I was overcome.
And I thought, I said,
well, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry that I represent
here and have benefited
from an institution that
has exploited and enslaved
people of this island.
I'm just sorry.
And, you know, she turned to
me, Michele Henry, and she said,
you know, don't be sorry.
Don't be sorry.
We Antiguans are proud
to have had some role
in the founding of
an institution that
would graduate Barack Obama.
Now that is generousness.
Here you are.
There's the poster.
They're selling Obama t-shirts
everywhere on the island.
Now my point is
just a simple one,
which is Annette
Gordon-Reed's dissent stands
for a very important truth.
You don't just go around
erasing this and that
and pretend things
didn't happen.
You know, there are pros
and cons about the shield
controversy, but one thing--
we must not forget that
Harvard Law School is linked
with slavery, that Harvard
Law School owes great debt
to the enslaved
people of Antigua,
and that it's part of
this great university
that it is so great that it can
recognize in itself the truth.
Veritas.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- So, thank you so much
for the invitation.
I'm very honored and it's
a pleasure to be here.
Thanks the Radcliffe, and
thanks, President Faust,
for the invitation.
I want to tell you that this
talk is related to Harvard
but may not be
related to Harvard.
And I'd like to see how we all
come to terms with the fact
that I'm not a historian.
I have to come to terms with
that, you know, somehow.
But there will be
lots of images.
I will not describe them.
So, there's a lecture or kind
of a concept in the images,
and there's a concept
in the words that I do.
And I would like to
invite you to think
about your own memories
when you think,
and when you look at this work.
This originated when I
was a student at Harvard,
kind of the notion of
architecture and memory.
I was very interested
in that as a research,
my own personal research.
And that kind of continued.
So, as an architect
and a teacher,
I've been investigating through
design and design pedagogy
the relations between
space and memory,
between architecture and memory.
I'm interested in the notion
that memory is an action.
Memory is not an object.
Memory is a verb, not a noun.
As an action, to remember is
to be present, is to say here
we are.
To be present in our complex
present as academics,
as architects, as
historians, as intellectuals,
as public intellectuals,
demands a louder and fearless
truth-speaking and
truth-seeking about our past
and also about ongoing
plights against humanity,
such as human trafficking,
genocides, present-day slavery,
and incarceration, as well.
So, few words have
been so ubiquitous
in contemporary culture
as the word memory,
impacting historiography,
psychoanalysis, visual arts,
performing arts, poetry, media,
landscapes, architecture,
public space.
So, as a result,
architects and artists
find themselves playing
an important role
in what we could call public
discourses about history
and memory.
Architecture is inherently
a practical and public art.
It is a practical art
insofar the purpose
is the driving force, why a
work is called into being.
[PHONE RINGING]
I hope it's not mine.
[LAUGHTER]
No, it's not mine.
OK, thank you.
So, let me recap.
So, it's a practical
art insofar that purpose
is the driving force, why a
work is called into being.
It is a public art in that
the presence of the work
constructs the space
for public appearance,
in the terms that Hannah
Ardendt described it,
the space for public appearance.
So, historically, the
architectural [INAUDIBLE]
to create a theater for
action and of memory.
And we can think that landscapes
and buildings, while framing--
becoming catalysts for
the process of memory,
serve to frame human experience.
It is in the face of
catastrophes, historic traumas,
and human injustices that the
architects and public artists
public roles become increasingly
complex, problematic,
and, we only hope, necessary.
We only hope.
So, how do we position
ourselves when
working with these
kinds of projects,
both as teachers, as
architects, as students?
Think of this.
The word memorial--
it's historic role
is to preserve a
memory of the past
and provide conditions for
new responses in the present.
This is one of the
maps that my students
do dealing with
Rhode Island slavery.
So, think about this point.
When we say, this is the
public space of the city,
we usually mean unofficial
monumental space, which,
using Walter
Benjamin's words, is
reserved for the celebration
of the history of the victors.
Memorials and historic
landmarks usually
celebrate that
memory of those who
have succeeded at the expense
of the forgotten memory of those
who have not.
It forgets the nameless
and the vanquished.
According to Hannah
Arendt, political equality
means visibility.
Conversely, political
inequality and invisibility
go hand in hand.
So when we think of institutions
of slavery and its legacies,
we should look at them
through the lenses of special
practices-- segregation,
migration, invisibility,
you know, feels--
you can think all
of the words that we
have used are related to
forms of spatial practice.
But let's think about this.
Democracy, as Claude
Lefort tells us,
is based on uncertainty
and legitimized
by the declaration of rights,
that is, the right to declare.
Democratic public spaces based
on contestation, on debate,
on the appearance of others--
those others, who as an
enigma of a face that resists
possession, cannot be fully
known and can never be reduced
to content, as Emmanuel Levinas
philosopher would have said.
So, I think to a large extent,
the success of democracy
and of public space can be
measured in its capacity
to encourage and assist in
the process of disruption
of that history of the victors.
We can see this.
Hopefully we'll do something.
But I'm interested in thinking
about these kinds of notions
of public space in relation
to campuses, in relation
to speech.
The National Museum
just opened in DC
means much more than a building.
Our project in Nantes is more
than a riverfront landscape.
There are significant
reinscriptions,
you know, of history and
memory in public life.
These projects are witnesses
to our actions in the present.
Our actions in the present.
So, philosophers
like Giorgio Agamben
have theorized the precision
of the witness in--
as the basis of an ethical
political relation insofar
as the witness answers to
the suffering of others
without usurping the
place of the other.
That these were the history that
we were talking about before.
Again, the witness answers
to the suffering of others
without usurping the
place of the other.
So, there's a limit
to representation,
both in writing and
history and in speaking.
So, witnessing is a way
of seeing and listening
that requires an acceptance
of vulnerability.
It requires a renunciation
of the will to mastery.
For us, trauma--
theories, [INAUDIBLE]
argues, to bear witness
to the truth of suffering
of a traumatic event is to
bear witness to that event's
incomprehensibility.
This poses problems for
forms of representation,
teaching, writing, and creating
that attempts to respond
to the suffering of others.
Perhaps we can only
breathe your name.
Breathe your name.
So, aesthetics should be
at the service of ethics.
This is the attitude that I
try to bring to my teaching,
to my projects, and to our
collaborative work with artist
and professor here at GSD, and
involves an approach of art,
architecture and
landscape as mediums
that are capable of shedding
limited set of truth and values
in a space that is located
between question, publics,
and practices.
Questions, publics,
So, when we dealt with
slavery in Rhode Island,
the history of slavery
in Rhode Island,
with a series of design
studios that are geared,
as a pedagogical approach,
geared to create conditions
for students to encounter
stories that they cannot
fathom.
And I want to think Jim Campbell
for all his fantastic work
and his help in setting
up these discussions.
But these are an attempt
to construct and understand
history in our present and
think of a field of [INAUDIBLE]
called cultural sustainability.
Think about how we deal
with present conditions.
So, students worked
with mapping,
students worked with
[? coast, ?] students
did memory boxes,
worked on texts,
created images like this one.
This is Linden Place, the DeWolf
family mansion in Bristol,
Rhode Island and a montage
of Carl Walker's work.
But let's remember,
as Jim Campbell also
mentioned many times, 55% of
the mill workers in Rhode Island
by 1830 were children.
So, we have to think about that.
So, how do we think
about projects
dealing with the coast
of Rhode Island for today
and for tomorrow?
This is one of the concepts.
These are exercises.
I'll just go very
quickly on this.
But the point that
I'm trying to make
is that students can
become cultural activists.
And interdisciplinary work
is what matters in my mind.
So, let me go quickly
to a couple of minutes
on the project for the Memorial
to the Abolition in Nantes
that we designed
with [INAUDIBLE]
And let's remind us that,
basically, today, slavery still
exists and does so globally,
despite the fact that it's now
globally illegal.
And it's a question that
we have to ask ourselves.
And this question
needs a reinforcement
in the consciousness and
emotional comprehension
of all of us and new
generations, as well.
So [INAUDIBLE],
mayor, prime minister,
and our kind of direct sponsor,
let's say, of this project
wrote, "By building the memorial
on the banks of the Loire
in the heart of a city, at
the point from which the slave
trading [INAUDIBLE]
departed, we recalled
that the fact that the struggle
for freedom and dignity
for all human beings is a
fundamental cause inextricably
linked to our vision of society.
The memorial hopes
to become a living
place for collective commitment
to the memory of the past
and to continue our struggle
for recognition and promotion
of human rights."
This is a key point in
public space, in public life,
in public speech.
How do we deal with our present?
So, the city has
created this kind
of [INAUDIBLE] that connects
the museum to the memorial.
And you can see kind of an
aerial view of the site.
And I'll show you, just to
give you a sense of scale,
this is Radcliffe,
and this is Harvard.
Can you see the map?
Just quickly, this is
Radcliffe Quad, where we are,
and this is Massachusetts Hall.
This is the scale
of the memorial,
just to give you
a sense of scale.
The relation is basically
the same distance, twice,
because you walk it
up above and below.
So, the concept here
is that the city itself
has turned its architecture
and official public space
into a grand reinscription,
and I would say disruptive
in narrative intervention.
They not only accepted this,
but embraced this concept,
that this space, beyond
its symbolic purpose,
it's useful to
commemorate the event
and to think about the present.
So, we excavated.
We have found an
underground space.
And we transformed
that underground space
on the coast of a river,
and we transform it
into a place for people to
come and read and to think.
So, the project celebrates
the great rupture of abolition
with the thrust of a
great slanted plate, which
emerges through the
city and cuts the soil.
About five centuries of struggle
are inscribed in this glass.
We also inscribed, kind of as
a form of an urban archive,
the names of 2000
expeditions from Nantes,
that departed from Nantes.
And you see people looking
at them and walking,
and you see beautiful names.
You can see La Therese.
There's a ship called L'Amour.
Can you believe that?
The Three Marys.
Another Love, you know.
And they are all
navires negriers.
So, I want to invite you
to think about the notion
that when we walk, we think.
When we walk, we evoke.
And this is part of what we do.
The stones themselves matter.
And the place itself only can be
done if we really pay not only
respect and homage to the
people who suffered this story,
but actually we pay
homage to the people who
made this possible, the
builders, the people who
put their hands and their
knowledge into making
our buildings possible.
This is, to me,
what matters when
we do buildings, when we do
architecture anywhere we do it.
How do we engage with others?
And that's an ethical dimension.
So, cutting the concrete, going
underground and transforming
this, which is kind of
flooding with the water
daily, into a place
that can be inhabited,
creating a dam underground,
a complex structure.
This space is about 150
meters below ground.
That's a football field
and a half length.
You know, and you see how
it goes and how it moves,
and you're--
I'm just getting
close to the finish.
So, you see how this
glass transforms
the ground of a city.
And very significant moments
of opening of the memorial.
And I want to pay significant
homage to Madame [INAUDIBLE]
who's here and will
speak later, for her work
not only to support the
memorial and her speech
at the opening of
the memorial, but her
work specifically
to bring justice,
to bring the law that is under
your name to the public eye
in France and in the world.
So, that law is inscribed
in the memorial,
or a good portion of
the law is inscribed
in the memorial in a space that
looks at the Palace of Justice.
So, we have people visiting.
We have people reading.
We have people
inhabiting a space that
relates to the water,
a water that perhaps
is the only witness, somehow,
to the story, a water that
filters, a water that comes down
through the glass, a water that
marks words, words like freedom.
And you see people coming.
You see groups and schools
reading and writing
and thinking and discussing.
And yes, these are my two kids.
And, basically-- and we have
Martin Luther King that is also
inscribed there, and you
see emotion that happened,
and you see also revolt. A
moment two years ago when
Angela Davis was
visiting the memorial
as a kind of a
day of remembrance
of the abolition of slavery.
So, I'm going to finish with
just one word, which is this--
When we did this project,
we didn't know the outcome.
I mean, we knew
that space matters.
And space and memory
are totally connected.
So, when you look
at the memorial
from the Palace of Justice,
you see a line, horizontal line
on the ground of the city.
But when you go to the
memorial, you see justice.
You imagine justice, or perhaps
justice that needs to be done.
There's no inscription that
says, think about justice.
But you do that, because we
can kind of construct it,
that relation, that dialogue.
And that dialogue
happens in space.
And that dialogue happens
when I saw this woman visibly
emotional looking
at the memorial
and visiting the memorial.
And I heard footsteps running.
And I heard-- and I saw her son.
And I saw this embrace.
And I want to close by saying,
using Levinas's citation
of Dostoyevsky, who
also was interestingly
connected to James Baldwin's
understanding of memory,
as far as I read.
So, Dostoevsky says all of us
are responsible of everything,
of everyone before everyone,
and myself more than others.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK, this is a time for us to
ask one another any questions
that we may have about the
presentation or discuss it--
discuss amongst ourselves.
Anyone have anything,
or do we want to go?
Yes, we can go.
Well, I just-- if you'd--
no questions of ourselves?
Questions from the audience.
We're supposed to--
they're supposed
to be bringing us cards.
Sure.
What is the response?
Do you have any--
Julian, did you have any
opposition to the Nantes--
I mean, what was the order,
what was the nature of it,
and what was the strength of it?
And how did it come
from, If there was anyone
who objects to this idea?
- Well, there was strong
opposition, you know,
and if it was not for
the support of the mayor,
Jean-Marc Ayrault, this project
would have not been built.
- What did they say?
I mean, what exactly--
- Well, they said we don't want
the city to feel the guilt,
you know, of its own
history, being the largest,
premier slave trading
port in France,
that basically grew
economically through the trade--
sugar that came to Nantes.
So, one of the things was kind
of public guilt. You know, what
do we do with public guilt?
And the argument that was made
was more like recognition.
And the mayor was extremely
supportive of that.
That's one thing.
Second thing is that there was
a history before the memorial,
which was the Les Anneaux de
la Memoire, a very significant
exhibition that happened in 1992
that had about half a million
people visiting the Chateau
de Nantes, the duc de
Bretagne, basically to
visit and to understand
the history of its own city.
So, it seems to
me that there are
some aspects of the
story that were extremely
important in the public eye.
The people who did not
want this to happen
came from either
families or more,
I would say, right-wing
kind of areas
of the people in the city,
but once the memorial opened,
it was embraced.
Once the memorial opened, it
was embraced by the people
and visited.
And everybody brings family
to visit the memorial,
and they see this as a unique
project, both in the city
and in France.
And I think-- I'm
personally very
moved to have been simply
be able to visualize this,
to visualize this project and to
inhabit that space that nobody
has ever seen
before we opened it.
It is a space that was
excavated that no one has ever
seen before, because it was just
simply residue of construction
of the ports.
- Dan, for the
people in Antigua,
have you heard any response
to them about the shield?
Or do you-- can
you sort of predict
what they might say about it?
- Well, they are
aware of the decision.
And they have copy of the
opinion and of your dissent.
So, this is-- these
are people who
are really keeping track here.
There's no question that they're
not interested in reparation
or anything like that.
That's not what interests them.
What interests them
is some recognition
by this great
university that they--
that we owe them a
debt, an historic debt.
And there are many possible
ways-- they don't have enough--
when I was down
there, there were
lines to use laptop
computers in the library.
There are not enough computers.
There's also not
enough fresh water.
And they're having problems
with their justice system.
So, I mean, there are so many
things we could do to help.
- I think I should
probably say what
happened with the dissent,
what my rationale was.
You know, this whole question--
a lot of it comes
from, I mean, I
think the Royall must
fall was influenced
by the movement at Oxford
about Oriel College,
Rhodes must fall.
There was a statue of Cecil
Rhodes on top of Oriel College,
that I've been into
a number of times
and never knew he was up there.
He was up pretty high.
And the thinking was
that this was an affront.
And there was a student
movement on those lines.
On our committee, we were
talking about the best way
to proceed.
And it's not that
I think that it
would be a matter
of erasing history
just by moving the shield.
The idea I had was that--
and I talked in the dissent
about the difference
between a representation
of a person who
can't be reconstituted, someone
like Cecil Rhodes or John
Calhoun, a flag like
the Confederate flag
that has a history and a past
and is so imbued with a spirit
that you can't, to
my mind, do away
with what that meant in
terms of the Confederacy
or what it meant in
its modern incarnation
with people taking it and using
it to oppose civil rights,
and when it's hauled out
and why it's hauled out.
That's-- it's not like that.
Three bushels of
wheat are symbols.
When my husband and I
were here as students,
we had no idea what it meant.
I thought, well, OK,
sheaves of wheat.
Fertility, knowledge,
what is this?
We really didn't know.
And we had wheat pennies, but
wheat is a symbol of abundance
and so forth.
So, we sort of think, abundance
of wisdom or something--
you give it a name.
So, it could mean anything.
And it struck me that
since we were having
our centennial, what we could
do would be to have a ceremony
and reconstitute the law
school and the sheaves of wheat
to be in honor of
the people whose
labor gave Isaac Royall the
money to build the law school.
It's the power of law, what
we do is transformative.
We could make the
symbol about whatever
we want it to be about.
And my fear-- and to
have that powerful symbol
there go across the world every
time Harvard Law School went
anywhere, I thought
would be powerful,
that the people on the Royall
plantation would be remembered.
And they would be remembered
in a way that would be living
and would go forward.
It's nice to have a
display in the law
school and the
special collections
and talk about it amongst
ourselves when students come.
But it would be
different to have
Harvard Law School linked--
Harvard Law School that under,
I think, the modern ages
of Harvard Law School when the
shield was actually used more--
Harvard has a
tradition, law school
has a tradition
of public service.
Many people were
involved in civil rights.
That legacy could be
linked to the old legacy
to make something new.
We're not bound by
the past in that way.
So, that was my thinking.
It's not from any love or
respect of Isaac Royall,
but the Royall plantation was
not about Isaac Royall, to me.
The Royall plantation was
about the enslaved people
who lived there.
And that is the story.
And we could make
the story what we
wanted it to be rather
than being hostage
to Isaac Royall and his family.
So, that was my thinking.
Ceremony, reconstitute it, we
go forward with a different--
perhaps add the word, you
know, justice, for justice
to the shield and make
that association complete.
So, that's what my thinking was.
It was not out of
isn't Royall great.
- Can I just--
I just wanted to
add a few things.
I mean, for one, I
think what is really
important is that
whatever we do,
that we don't take
the steps that we're
taking as a kind of an effort
to end the conversation
or to end our engagement
with this history,
but really that we
commit ourselves
to a continued conversation
of this history
and a continued confrontation
with this history.
And I think the worst
thing we could do
is kind of to cleanse our
institutions from this history
and then to say, oh,
we took care of that
and now we don't have to
worry about it anymore.
No, I think we need to
continue to engage with this.
And then I thought,
maybe the experience
of the city of
Nantes in some ways
is actually quite
relevant to our situation
here because, obviously, Nantes
is not a city that was, itself,
the site of mass enslavement.
It is not a city that
was characterized
by slave plantations.
And it is a city in
which, presumably,
though I don't know
that for a fact,
but in which presumably
many people don't really
know anymore that it had
this very significant link
to the slave trade and
to Caribbean slavery.
And that is, I think, quite
similar to the situation
we're facing here at Harvard.
And so it would actually be
quite interesting to learn,
for us to learn from
the Nantes experience
to see how you can memorialize
this history on the one hand,
but also how you can encourage
a continued conversation
on that history and how
you, as Julian mentioned,
how you can persuade people
who are reluctant to engage
in this debate to eventually
persuade them to actually,
to engage these kinds of issues.
I think there is a
lesson in it for us,
though I don't know exactly
what that lesson is.
- Well, one of the things that's
happening at the law school
now, we're going to be
encouraging people to do,
that since we have the royal
plantation, not very far, is--
and Janet Halley is doing this,
encouraging people to visit.
I've been there.
And they do a great
interpretation,
very illuminating interpretation
about slavery in New England
and the lives of
the people there.
Maybe have our--
well, obviously,
have our students go there.
I would like, as part
of what I thought
would go on after a perhaps
reconstituted shield
and re-dedication,
we would be, we
would have more of a connection
to the people in Antigua.
Maybe students, some connection
there to keep the thing going
instead of just letting it go.
But that-- any kind of
experiences from other places
should help inform us.
Here's a question for you.
Professor Beckert, thank
you for your presentation
and ongoing commitment to
justice for enslaved Africans'
descendants.
You said the solution must
be economic and not just
rhetorical or symbolic.
Do you support reparations
to specific organizations
who build African
self-determination?
I'm sorry for putting
you on the spot.
- OK, no, no, no,
that's just fair
because I ended my talk
exactly on this notion.
And honestly, that was
very much the subject
of our conversations
this morning.
And yes, as I said, I think
it is important to acknowledge
this history.
It is important to know
what that history is.
And we have made some
progress in this process.
But I think we also need
to very much keep in mind
what was being said today.
This is a history that is
about massive violence.
This is a history of racism.
And this is also a history
of massive dispossession,
as was also mentioned
earlier today.
And all of the violence, the
racism, and the dispossession
has--
it's not just of relevance
to understanding the past,
but it's also very
much of relevance
to understanding the present.
And in that way, I think
there is a material
dimension to this issue.
And there is a need for
institutions, or perhaps
nations, who have greatly
benefited from exploitation,
racism, enslavement, and
dispossession-- there
is a responsibility to
address these past injustices,
and also address them
in material terms.
What this exactly looks
like, I can't tell.
But I think the importance
is to acknowledge this
and then to have a
conversation among a community,
for example, a
university community,
to see what the proper steps
are that should be taken.
- Julian, and I
thought this myself,
what would a memorial to
slavery at Harvard look like?
And how do you
garner your support?
- And how?
Sorry?
- How do you garner
your support?
The first one,
what-- if you were--
what would a memorial
at slavery look--
at Harvard look like?
- I think it's a question
that I cannot answer,
because in order to conceive or
think through such an endeavor
once requires time
to think about it.
And, to me, it's
not that I'm trying
to sort of short-change or sort
of shy away from the response,
is actually that there
may be other ways
in which one can think of this.
I am personally more
interested in the word memory
than in the word memorial
even though we have built it.
I mean to say that how we
think about memory, relation
to the past, but
memory is remembering.
You know, James Baldwin's
unfinished book,
Remembering This House, the
notion of remembering a house.
So, then the question
that I ask myself is,
if I can follow up with that, is
once we think of this history,
we somehow shed light over
a portion of a history.
You know, imagine a lamp.
You don't shed light
over the totality
of the history of slavery.
So, some aspects we can see.
Some aspects we cannot see.
But what we can see,
we cannot unsee.
And this is an important
aspect of the question
of the lamp of memory.
And the question I ask myself
is once we see something,
it continues to be with us, so
how do we allow that what we
see to interrupt our
present, meaning how can
we hear the voices of
those who are not present?
How can we see these
faces that we see here?
But how can we understand that
the retrospective projection
of meaning is very complex.
So, for me, one of the biggest
questions I ask myself,
and perhaps it's a question
for the university, perhaps,
is how do we deal with
our present conditions?
How do we invite our students'
interdisciplinary work
to consider the present?
Be that mass incarceration,
be that sex trafficking,
or human trafficking
today, which are
enormous and quite significant.
So, if there was a kind of
a memorial I would think
of more like an institution
that is an ongoing project that
never finish, never finishes,
because perhaps to repair--
and I'm just going
to use a Hebrew word.
Tikkun is to repair.
Tikkun olam is to
repair the world.
And perhaps we are
all here trying
to do our best to
repair what we can.
And to me, that's something that
I would like to think about,
perhaps the university
could engage with.
It's a conversation first.
- Dan this was one
to you, but I might
be able to answer
part of this as well.
To what extent do you
think the legacy of slavery
at HLS affected curriculum
or sustained the development
of legal thought at HLS?
- That's a great question.
Basically, what happened
before the Civil War
is question of memory, with
the Confederate leaders
and the Union leaders
remembering being
taught very different things.
The Confederate-- one of
the Confederate leaders
was held here in Castle Island
and wrote an irate letter
to his law professor,
Emory Washburn,
saying that he didn't understand
why Emory isn't supporting him,
because he, after all, was
fighting for the state's rights
that Emory Washburn taught
him in the classroom
at Harvard Law School.
Washburn sent him a book,
by the way, to read.
But in all seriousness, one of
the things that the Civil War
episode at Harvard
Law School shows
is that there was an effort,
a very deliberate effort,
by Charles Warren, and I know
you're the Charles Warren
Professor and I'm the Charles
Warren Visiting Professor,
but the first history
of Harvard Law School
was a three-volume
history, only one century,
written by Charles Warren.
Charles Warren essentially
took the Civil War out
of the history of the school.
And he did it very deliberately,
because at that point
the school was reaching
out to its Southern alumni
and bringing in the former
Confederate officers who
survived and the former
Confederate leaders.
There were 27 in Jefferson
Davis's government.
They were now becoming leaders
of the anti-Reconstruction.
They were becoming mayors
of Atlanta, governors
of South Carolina, and they
were being welcomed back
into the fold at
Harvard Law School.
Now, to do that,
you need to redefine
what the Civil War is about.
And one of the
things that we have
been able to ascertain
through the letters
and notes of the
students is that everyone
thought that the war
was about slavery when
the war was being fought.
So, it was slavery that
drove the Union students
to volunteer.
It was slavery that was the--
that caused the fights that
went into Harvard Square.
They emptied the classroom
fighting each other.
It was slavery.
Suddenly, it-- after
the war is over,
it becomes convenient
to redefine
the war about something else.
States' rights, theories of
constitutionality, you know,
now we've resolved
it, so we can move on.
And let's forget
about segregation.
Let's forget about racism.
And I'm afraid that
one of the, on my mind,
one of the worst chapters
of the history of the school
was the 20 years under Langdell,
when Langdell essentially
wrote out racism
and civil rights
from the curriculum
of the school.
- Here's a question for
both of us, I guess.
What are the next steps at the
law school beyond the new seal?
Well.
OK.
All right.
I'm the moderator.
I'm not supposed to--
[LAUGHTER]
Well, there's still a
lot of student interest
in bringing about a more
inclusive curriculum, as they
describe it.
There are discussions
about that, discussions
about a diversity of
professors, in terms of the way
they teach the
kinds of subjects,
bringing race more
into discussions.
Very often, in a
contracts case or just
to make an example of civil
procedure or other things,
there's a surface,
what the issues are--
there are surface
issues involved,
but there are
racial aspects of it
that student would like to
be brought into the mix.
It's sort of difficult.
There's some thinking
it's difficult to talk
about race in classes.
Some people are
uncomfortable doing that.
I teach criminal procedure,
which, race, obviously,
is all-- is shot throughout
the Fourth Amendment
jurisprudence, and
actual jurisprudence,
but the actual
practice of policing.
So, it isn't-- it's not a
difficult thing in my subject
area.
But there's much more
talk about pedagogy,
how to raise these
kinds of issues.
There's a lot of
things going on.
I think the shield controversy
sort of came and went,
but the continuing discussion
about transformation of law
school is very much there.
Do you have any
thoughts about, any more
about what you're seeing?
- Well I agree with all
of what you just said.
I mean, the students
yearn for context.
They-- it's one thing--
what we have gotten
from Langdell
is a formal curriculum that's
still remarkably the same
as it was in the 1880s.
You know?
And the legal formalism
stripped context
from the life of the law.
And I think the students
yearn to have it brought back.
And many of our colleagues
are working hard
on this, this issue to make the
legal doctrines contextualized.
I also think that the
representation on the faculty
is important.
We're approaching 20%
Asian-American enrollment.
At the moment, there's only one
tenured Asian-American faculty
out of 91 or 92.
And I think that the
students want a faculty
that they can identify with,
that are their role models.
And that involves gender, but
involves ethnicity and race
as well.
- I mean, it's--
I will say one
word for formalism.
I mean, part of
the answer to that
is that there's a concern
on the pushback on sort
of changing curriculum or
doing things too differently is
that there's a benefit, at
least first year, to focusing
on analysis, focusing on law,
understanding law as it exists.
And certainly context is always
going to be important there,
but you don't want--
I mean, I'm channeling
other people.
You do not want a
strictly politics
class, where people get to
talk about current events
or whatever.
And it's-- that's the
fear, that you go too far.
And so, what we're
trying to do has
been to balance the
sort of, the case
method and the Socratic
method to accommodate
new understandings and different
perspectives on things.
And a lot of people
want to do it.
We have faculty
workshops talking
about how to teach difficult
courses, State v. Man,
a very famous court
case involving slavery.
How do we talk about
these kinds of things?
And cautionary notes
about it's difficult,
because there might
be some students who
are upset about that.
There is no-- the
difficulty is there's
no one viewpoint about
all of these things.
One of the critiques
of this notion
of my idea of having the
shield as something that
is sort of a living symbol
is that some people don't
want to be reminded of that.
And why should African-Americans
be reminded of that?
And I have a different
perspective on that,
but there is no one viewpoint.
And you have to
consider all of them
and try to come to
some sort of balance.
So, it's going to be--
it's an interesting time.
I mean, it's challenging, but
that's what we're here for,
to solve problems.
That's what the law
school is about.
And I think we're going
to rise to that challenge.
Did you say, have something--
oh, Alexandra, if you may.
- Yeah, go ahead.
- I just wanted to make a quick
comment, just from a student
perspective.
I'm now a student at Harvard
for the second time in my life
and consider myself
very lucky to be one.
But I do think there is a
desire from students, as well,
to have kind of like a
mission-driven education.
Like you go to
Harvard, and there's
this emphasis on how do
you use your education
to be good, to better society.
And I think sometimes
when you move
from the college to the
professional schools,
that mission-driven sense
gets a little bit lost.
And so maybe one
practical way would
be in our professional
schools to kind of emphasize
that there is--
our professional schools are
also mission driven, right?
Like being at the
business school,
you should have a sense of
going out there and bettering--
using your education
to better society.
So maybe that's another actual--
- Yeah, I would say
for the law school,
from the time I was
there, its public service
has been at the heart of it.
We have time for
one more comment.
- Can I make one quick
comment on this issue?
When you asked me about
what would the memorial look
like, you know, I was a bit
caught off guard, but the--
- You thought of something.
- Yeah.
It's good.
I appreciate that.
But the concept that I'd like
to share with you is this.
I just took a cursory
research at the Harvard series
of schools in
terms of their work
that they are doing with
questions of present day
slavery.
And there are many
initiatives happening today,
at the school of health,
at the Kennedy School
of Government, the
Harvard Law Review,
you know, and you
can keep going.
And this is happening,
as well, in the world.
There are many
initiatives happening.
So, one, going to the
question of mission-driven,
would it be possible to conceive
that this institution may help
frame a new 21st-century
abolitionism movement,
or abolitionist movement?
Help contribute to that?
What would it look like?
I have no idea.
Why?
Well, there are a lot of
people today in conditions
that are illegal, but
they are still slavery.
So, the question to me
is not only the past.
Yes, the past, of course--
we need to keep working at it.
But how do we deal with
our present conditions?
And that will help
better society today,
just as an offer.
- That's a great note to end on.
Thank you very much Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]